[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: So I'd like to talk
about the topic of curation,
which has become a huge topic
these days as we try to manage
the overwhelming
information flows competing
for our attention.
We're all suffering from intense
information and bandwidth
anxiety.
We're like a 56K modem trying
to download 10,000 hours of HD
video through that pipeline.
We simply lack the
biological hardware
to actually take in all of the
information that's competing
for our attention today.
So curation has
become the buzzword.
The information diet of every
single person is now the craze.
How are you going to curate
your information diet?
Are you going to just
create a filter bubble?
Because that's not curation.
Curation cannot just be
filtering out when you
don't want.
Curation needs to
be about creating
the conditions in which
you can discover what
you didn't know you wanted.
When you can discover what you
didn't know would be useful.
Curation should be
all about serendipity,
which is look for something,
find something else,
and realize that
what you found was
more conducive to your
needs than what you
thought you were looking for.
So the question today becomes,
can we design algorithms,
can we design apps
that can leverage
contextual computing, big
data, finding patterns,
create random patterns,
so on and so forth,
to engineer
technologically-mediated
information serendipity?
Because that would
really upgrade
the valuable,
meaningful, data sets
that we're able to absorb
from those information fields.
So that's how I feel about
the pivotal role of curation
nowadays.
And we need to figure it out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]